W
CREATE.SEMIE WA STO OUT, JAMIE,W
HILL THE DAYN SHE HAD WITH JIMAH
CONVERSATION HAPPENED AFTE
ION ONNUY 7th.LLEY AND LIZY NDSS
LADIY  AISLE.RE G E, I'M STANDGH
MEP YO
HI A
YOU G IS
CHENEY ND JIJORDAN'S HELT.
NO, B THE THAT YO
ITING AND
RIGHT NOW,SPSO B
MAPLG THIS SHOE REPUBLICANS IN
TOUCH AND IN TUNE WITH THE
FORMER PRESIDENT.
OT OF
WHO FORMER PREDE DID N
BELIEVE WHAT HE WAS SAYING
US E
NG S SAYING OR IT W
D
REATING THOSE LIBO
ALLY OF THE NG WITHPERSON.
KS VER
CL BUT HE
WAS ONE OF SEVERAL P
JANUARY 6th WE I
WHITE
S CALLING THEM AS THISONTOL HILR
HE HAS GOTOUT THIS WHEN TH WER
ESSENTIALLY BETHFORMER
PRESIDENT TO PUTTEMENT
TELLING PEOPLE TO LEAVE THE
CAPIL,OM
T COLE  WHAT WAHAPPENING.
BUT I THINWHARY 6th ANVERY Y TET
WHAT HAPPENED, IS EVENHO
LAYED A ROLE I
THIS, THE DAY OFD HOLY , THIS I.
T THIS HAS LED
HINK THA
S NOT  SURPRISING.DS
I IN
THAT IT WAS  O
THERE THAT REAL
ANTHNSEQUEN YI KAITLAN -- GON,
PERSPECTORDAS
PERPUAHE LIE
PRON DAY JA6th,F NO, SEVERAL A U
IS REALLY AB HETUATED THE BIG Lh
NG H, LOOK, SO
LEK CONF
WHAT WE KNEW WD. THINKRE
THAT THIS BO UBECAUSE
OF T
HAPPENED IN JANUARY --N D CERTNL
PROCEEDED IT.
>> THINK WITMILLEY
SOMETHING Y
KEEP IN MIND
E WH
IDWHEN HD SELECTAS THE CHAIRMAN
CHIEF OF, LE WOUTEN GO T TO GET
SO SEE HIM  CONNECT WITH I
GIVEN THE EVENTS AND NOW THAT
THIS IS ALL CO
INK YOU HAVE TINOF THE CONTEXTI.
IC SO THAT
PEOPLE HAVE TO REA BOOK.
>> H
THATION, TS
ST FOR STORY AND WEY,UA
LE ARO